France's wanji is seeking custody of his
grandchild who survived the cult in
eastern Kenya and is now in government
care
his daughter was one of Pastor Paul
McKenzie's followers
survivors say he convinced many of them
to starve first their children and then
themselves to death before the end of
the world so they could go to heaven
when Francis organized the rescue it was
too late for two of his grandchildren
the one who survived explained what
happened to his younger brother seith on
the day he was supposed to die he said
that the mum tried to suffocate Seth by
blocking both the northern mouth was
kicking the set was just still kicking
his legs okay
by that time they're not in bother
they just buried said while still alive
faith is among hundreds of people who've
been buried in the remote arid Forest to
where Mackenzie had called his followers
more than a month after they started
dying police started exhuming bodies at
the site people found alive abroad here
to malindi's town Hospital some of them
want to continue starving themselves to
death those who were already dead are
taken to the towns morgue next door
people familiar with the site and
survivors say that there are members of
the Colts militia and some of its
followers still alive hiding in the bush
and that there are hundreds more bodies
buried in the ground
this person's worked at the site but is
not authorized to talk
there are many signs that things are
still going on in that place you can see
people have been cooking in the houses
we came across a body that was recently
put in a house that we'd surged several
times one of their hands had been eaten
by a hyena
Mckenzie was arrested several times and
released even after his followers
started dying
he's now in police custody awaiting
charges governments launched a
commission of inquiry and is looking at
regulating preachers
people at other churches in the town of
malindi were wondering why nobody
stopped Mackenzie this one's led by
Bishop Thomas kakala
he says he's been alerting the
authorities to MacKenzie's dangerous
doomsday preaching for years this cultic
preachers
they centralize everybody to them not to
Jesus then they begin to manipulate
those people those people who love to
sell their properties and you bring the
money at his feet now he can bribe the
police he can Brave anybody with that
money you don't be worried you will get
the job the child protection officers
tell Francis they'll help him see
custody of his grandchild when he's
released from care
it was after Francis took journalists to
the site last month that the police
operation finally began
he says hundreds of lives could have
been saved including five-year-olds safe
Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera malindi Kenya